okay good morning I apologize for the
slight delay here welcome to the expert
panel so today we're going to answer any
questions you might have
we have Roger Gorman son John Folse and
Tom Wickham Jones who between the three
of them have probably over half a
century of experience you know with our
product so they should be answer be able
to answer a lot of your questions Roger
is going to do it ten minutes just sort
of introductory talk just a little
overview and while he's doing that
please you know think about any
questions you might have
I will be walking around and just you
know raise your hand if you have a
question I'll give you the microphone
and then you can ask the question
my name is aren't abusing I can answer
questions about you know like quality of
the product I can answer questions about
support as well John will be able to
answer questions about user interfaces
of course Tom about kernel technology
and Roger will you know algorithms are
any questions about that and of course
Tom can do the cloud as well all right
so Roger maybe maybe you can get started
thank you I just a reminder summary of
the things that came out in 10
specifically the ones that came out of
our algorithm R&D effort at Wolfram and
ok sorry about that can you guys hear me
so this is this is the this is state you
know we build these marketing pages and
we release and you can sort of scroll
through examples go through bullets so I
wanted to use sort of a postcard version
of each to summarize some of the things
that came out of the algorithm side of
of the house and so that's a little bit
brief
and this is also quite brief so here are
some of the major areas geometric
computing so I'm trying to give you the
elevator speech summary of it you know
so geometric regions are now first-class
citizens for visualization plot themes
Geographics and a lot more there's a lot
of other enhancements around the corners
and new visualization functions symbolic
sand numerix you've seen a lot of things
like finite elements formal operations
and and much more like symbolic
differential equations in etc I mention
signal processing the theme there is
sort of high-level operations for 2d
image processing making the 3d image
processing sort of complete or almost as
complete as 2d not quite but it's it's
very close advanced color stuff graphs
and networks so we did you know by now
we can proudly say that the graph the
network side of Mathematica is complete
it's by far the most comprehensive and
highest performing graph computation
system in the world so that's a very
reached a very mature and complete state
probability and statistics so this time
around we've done a lot of things to
promote time series as a data object
system-wide so it works pretty much with
everything that you could imagine and
it's a very good handle to to deal with
these things and we started out building
these because we have temporal processes
in particular time series processes and
all kinds of things so random processes
typically generate these data but in the
modern world you get them from
everywhere from devices and so on
and then control systems for the first
time you can actually do non-linear
control you can model nonlinear control
systems doing analysis and design so
this is a sentence each a little bit
elaborated so if we drill down something
here didn't quite work
I think your version it's not quite
right lots of things for geometry for
you to explore on these these marketing
pages and there are many talks no we
don't cover everything with talks in
this conference but most things and so
the big thing is is Regents properties
and solvers for for these regions you
know you have an overview and various
kinds of drill downs including finite
element based finite element sort of
straddles geometry in other areas this
is certainly not the correct Mathematica
visualization top themes everywhere and
plot themes everywhere and and and this
is something that probably you all will
be using something because it's very
very accessible and we'll we're adding
extensibility to too so if you want to
write your own plot theme that that will
be coming out for a book project for a
corporate project and whatnot how do I
switch over
come on one
Geographics so geographic is you know
first of all the graphics layer like
like graphics but increasingly will have
more sophisticated visualization
functions that sit on top of that
there's quite a few already but that's a
lot of things more coming
the symbolic numerix finite elements
symbolic differential equations
something that we haven't really done
improvements on for a while in
Mathematica but we're starting to push
that out again and so you'll see much
more coming there now you can do things
that no one ever knew that one could do
symbolically like like to event
differential equations and delay
differential equations symbolically or
inactive for showcasing things for doing
formal mathematics now operators such as
integrate or solve become problem
description languages that you can
reason about that you can manipulate
formally you can differentiate Laplace
transform and have it makes sense you
know differentiate with respect to
things so this is this is starting to
the higher level sort of second-order
mathematics second-order logic in the
system and this is kind of a start on
that lots of other improvements there
are lots of things that we probably
haven't even talked about in this there
there lots of little breakthroughs you
know so who knew that that for instance
when you solve a system of let's say
polynomial equations if we can generate
you know two hundred thousand solutions
for you in in a hundred seconds and
they're pretty innocent-looking it's
just the fact that polynomial systems
are very rich but we can now do that so
there's a lot of these barrier busting
you know breakthroughs for complexity
stuff
and then image and signal processing as
I said a lot of high-level stuff for for
for 2d in a barcode recognition various
kinds of recognition or detection
functions and convenience functions for
3d just about sort of complete you know
or not quite on par with 2d but it's
it's very very close and you know little
things like like colors so what's the
difference what's the distance between
two colors you know according to whom
so the thing is what you use for colors
you use what's called a perceptual color
model so it mimics what you experience
as a user and that's the kind of
distance you want to know about colors
we now have the capabilities to
represent them like that and that's
called an an lab color model and la be
color model and there's several more
that are really convenient that allows
you to reason about colors and design
colors and things so that's probably
something you might not have thought
about but it's actually useful in a wide
variety of areas the lots of things that
you know even even very even though
there isn't super much in signal
processing this time around peak
detection is really really useful
you actually want that a lot you know
and probability and statistics so this
is the sort of second major round of
doing random processes and as I said one
of the major thing was to make the temp
time series something that's a very
broad object that you use system-wide in
and even though it was born out of
random processes it's it's it's future
life in Mathematica is a broad container
that you use to to hold all kinds of
time-series basically that you want to
process we've done something here which
i think is kind of remarkable is you
know something that's it's fully
automatic time series processing there's
much richer models and so on there is
you know arch and GARCH and vector time
series but but there's something else
which is really really convenient which
is to search the space of all possible
time series models of all possible
orders
systematically so that Kim means that it
under the hood might use coal times
here's Moffatt they will search hundreds
of models it's really convenient
it means it's it's it's it's available
for more casual use and other things
that you I'm sure you know of depending
on where you come from like hidden
Markov models and so on the whole thing
is just much more powerful graphs and
networks so as I said you know in the
early introduction it's really really
complete now and the the pictured areas
from doing a traveling salesman which
you know is a breakthrough out where I
think right through that we can do
really large problems so that means that
that's something that you can actually
afford to use in a variety of contexts
so here you know to you know here's a
complete here some of the the bigger
other systems that do graphs and
networks most other things are very
niche and it's mathematic in the middle
competitor systems and around and so
even for scope is very complete but
there's there's no comparison for
performance I turn and there are little
things here that probably no one looks
at you know like I think that this is
really cool the complete complete
understanding of cycle structure of
graphs okay well we we picked an example
that you can explain in the elevator
like really finding that best dog walk
derived from a real problem at home yeah
okay so very complete very powerful at
this point in time and in control system
nobody has sort of put together except
sort of for research level codes to be
able to fully model nonlinear systems
and actually do control design and so
the big secret here is that you can make
a transformation that makes this
nonlinear system outwardly appear to be
linear without doing approximation and
it matters when the non-linearity is
kind of severe like for instance you
want to control a satellite and you have
satellite thrusters it's a highly
nonlinear system and it pays off to
actually have a good controller you want
to go through the through the extra work
in getting this level of performance out
of it
compared to classical standard linear
control theory we can do it uniquely
doable in a system like Mathematica and
that's so here's the the one sentence
summary right geometric regions
first-class citizens and so on that's
all I had thank you very much just to
remind you a little bit what sir
all right Thank You Roger
so now we just open the floor to
questions and if you have a question
please raise your hand and if you don't
have any questions then I'm gonna ask
some interesting questions much
healthier anybody there we go okay good
good good good good
so let me walk over here the second
question will be quicker but first
question I have to walk over and just
give the microphone back hello my name
is Raul Hernandez I work involved from
one of the things that Stephen has
mentioned a couple of times during the
conference is the possibility of having
many course many kernels computing for a
limited period of time as needed for
specific computations what would be the
best way of doing that through a
Mathematica do you mean today now or do
you mean at some time in the future yeah
at some time right right well I think
this is part of our this is this is a
development project that's part of our
cloud functionalities to the cloud
mechanisms that we have make it you know
they designed to sort of spin things up
on demand and down on demand and so
we're you know this this is a active
area of work that a Roman
made of romans here but this Romans
leading the effort to develop such such
functionality so I think Steven was
referring to the development project
rather than the existence of this but in
the context of the cloud I think it
makes total sense should there be a
graphical design language for the
Wolfram language equivalent to like a
UML there can be I mean we're looking at
actually a variety of these graphical
design language not for the whole
Wolfram language but sub languages so
I'm aware of maybe 150 of these
diagrammatic languages and at some point
we want to build that in you know on top
of the graph functionality we have for
instance that it behaves like a UML or a
sysml or reliability block diagram
editor or you can keep going pretty
pretty far here right I don't know if it
needs to be one for the Wolfram language
it's a that hasn't really I don't know
that I don't know if that would help
particularly every weekend do you have
any opinion about it yourselves since
you raised it
I think for large systems it makes sense
I mean most people just jump right into
a notebook right or jump right into
workbench and just start building things
and that's great
but if you're building a large system it
kind of has to be this design layer
between the requirements and the actual
code that I think I'm healthy then
you're talking about sort of one of
these domain languages like a
requirement definition language
something like that you know right and
one of the things that I would have some
concern about is the the Wolfen language
is a very expressive language where
language by which I mean English is
concerned it's you know we're into
thousands of functions and we think
really hard about naming these functions
and and and and trying to be able to
even as somebody who has no idea what
you know how to write code in our
language to be able to route read
through our code and get an idea of
what's actually going on and not rely on
these you know purely on you know fairly
elementary sorts of operations and I
would have some concern when we're
talking you know 6000 system symbols and
growing how well that would translate to
a visual expression but you know it
works very well as a as a linguistic
expression though I think that I mean I
can say other thing sorry um but um I
mean there's all sorts of things it can
mean it can also mean just something to
help you organize your code or get some
view of like call graph analysis and
we've built sort of things like this
actually what Ben she's quite a good
tool for you know extracting and we had
some you know mechanism just to see how
the different parts of you know your
code were interacting I think that that
sort of can be quite insightful of
course if I can display
can i interject something here sure yeah
so in no way does that preclude you from
using UML as an actual requirement
language the UML is mostly used as a
replacement for PowerPoint right there's
no actual execution going on in most UML
it's sort of a structured but there's a
partner of ours that work with UML and
with all the sort of UML editors or
systems out there like Rhapsody and I
forget there's like three of them that
makes a lot of its actually computable
you know and they can maintain their
certain kinds of things that you're
worried about that say you build a
satellite and each subsystem contribute
to the mass but there's a certain
maximum mass that you want to allow for
that satellite there's a certain maximum
energy drain that you can allow the
subsystems to do for that satellite and
to always sort of check and compute that
or even drill into sort of deeper
behavioral models so for instance system
auditor contains very deep behavioral
models as opposed to that very abstract
you know model and if you can automate
making that connection that's still very
very useful and then I think that could
be for any wolfram you know for any sort
of code including Mathematica willful
language code right and I'll just show
you what while we're talking about this
I've this is something that Abdul and
dogs here but and I've been working on
which is some you know new stuff not not
released but this is a flow graph of
blocks of code so this is we're starting
out with you know a program you know
some mathematical code like this and
then it's producing sort of looping
these are little sort of blocks so each
block you know there's like one entry
and one exit and then you sort of
connect these together and then of
course the job is you can then go and
rearrange them to sort of minimize jumps
or or or get a more efficient flow graph
so this is also a view into the into the
code and of course mathematic is a very
good tool for you know we can use graph
theoretic functions for sort of
rearranging this and then artist
yeah we can make some Surrey
arrangements of the code - let's well
you know it this this is the sort of
idea of you know this is also views into
the code and their graphs and things and
mathematic is good for that because you
also might want to use it for like
refactoring purposes you know your
career at youth you have your code but
you know if you move this function from
this module into some central thing you
can break you know you get a neater
arrangements I think this would be a
rich area for math mathematical work
that we're not you know we're not quite
tapping into that yeah okay thank you
next question is from Richard Mercer hi
I wonder if I could ask you to clarify
your strategy for mobile devices it
seems clear to me that did you expect
what mobile devices to use Wolfram cloud
/ Wolfram online and and that's that's
great but speaking for myself personally
I would love to see a native front-end
on my iPad John everybody's looking at
me hey I would love to see a native
front-end on my iPad - I actually do I
mean you know we have an internal
project of course the we've been
releasing huge amounts of Technology
this year we've had so many projects
going on and I mean basically it's a
little bit embarrassing but basically
what it comes down to is a company of
our size you know there's only there's
only so much oxygen for for so many
projects and
and I wanted to get something out before
now so I wouldn't have to have this
conversation with you but but I think
we're very close to a first release and
to be clear what I'm what I'm talking
about in terms of you know the initial
wave of technology that we have its iOS
non-android we're prepared to you know
to do some interesting stuff on Android
but we're just you know that we'll be
having a discussion about Android what
I'm sitting here next year so the and
it's much more focused on player type
technologies being able to consume
content that you created elsewhere and I
think that's you know maybe some of you
are very successful at creating content
on iPads my experience hasn't been very
good on that front you know it's a great
content consumption platform but but not
wonderful for content creation and we
have to work within you know of course
the hardware limitations and one of the
things about our company which is which
is a blessing and a curse is that we
have over 25 years of intellectual
capital built into Mathematica that's
great when it when stated that way when
stated the way of we have a 25 year old
codebase which now you want to make work
on a platform where things work
fundamentally differently I mean this
has been one of the big challenges for
us and so we've some things we've been
able to port over but some things we
really had to build again from scratch
and
were you know we've set high
expectations we spent 25 years setting
high expectations and and we're now
we're now a few years into this
development project of matching those
expectations from scratch so it's been a
challenge
that's my litany of excuses I could
probably come up with more if you want
there this I'd like to add one small
thing I mean we're now talking about
like Wolfram creating mobile
applications but of course with the
Wolfram cloud it's becoming relatively
easy to build your own mobile
application if you're so inclined like
if you're you know company or startup or
you know like university or government
user and you know you can call the cloud
and just you know build an instant API
and you know call that and get a result
back get a you know piece of tech spec
get a piece of XML or JSON back or you
know get an image back and that's
actually pretty easy to do with with the
cloud technology and I think you know if
you want to go that way that that's a
great way to you know use mobile
application as well
you know that's just in addition to
Wolfram you know building the mobile
applications and sort of building you
know like a desktop type application on
an on an iPad I mean that that's you
know that's a big that's a big challenge
next question is probably if I can say
one more thing just I mean you kind of
mentioned this in passing but for those
who may not have been paying close
attention the web story on mobile is a
pretty good story and we're very close
to to releasing an app which well
internally we've been calling it the
Wolfram cloud app I'm not sure exactly
how we're going to brand it in the App
Store but but which is a much better
experience for working with the cloud on
the mobile platforms than just going
through the native browser much more you
know much better interface for dealing
with touch and that sort of thing and
that and that is coming on both iOS and
Android
and the iOS version I expect to see
pretty soon Android probably before the
end of the year okay the next question
is from Chris read what is the outlook
for being able to paralyze nd soul for
example with a system of coupled
ordinary differential equations I mean
some of it is stub it some of them I
mean right now a lot of them what
happened to them you solve these
paralyzed
you know the linear algebra and you know
these things always come down to linear
algebra at the bottom and then your
algebra will be paralyzed you know if
you've got a multi-core machine it'll be
it is you know it is now has been for
years you know that's that's yeah I sit
on a 12 core machine it'll eat my
machine usually right
maybe you mean other you know maybe you
mean other things that sort of coarser
types of paralyzation you couldn't I
think I think we we don't unless you're
wanting to run multiple your problem you
can run multiple what do you mean Chris
do you mean you mean on five hundred
thousand processors already mean on four
yeah
you'd be able to solve those more
quickly yeah but what scale are we
talking about I mean so there's small
scale it works today there will be more
coming okay okay very large scale which
you can also do if you happen to have
mmm that's it 500 course 500,000 course
or something like that that's a little
bit farther away okay but that very
problem of how to partition these big
problems it's a nice graph problem in
fact there is a graph function called
graph partition that's designed to do
just that to provide to set up and
compute the minimal interfaces of
information flow between these clusters
or processors okay thank you
next question is from Anderson Gaudio am
i pronouncing that right yes after a big
effort the you have made and last last
year about undo say multiple level undo
which is very important for us there is
another thing that you couldn't make
another fort to make easier our work
with Mathematica this is a easier to use
the book system my question is in the
course of the life of a people of more
than 50 years its it do you think it's
possible to implement a system in which
you could execute Mathematica step by
step and passing the mouse over are very
able to see it as well oh is it possible
absolutely if that's your question we're
done
look you know so we have you know we
have a certain number of debugging or
you know a certain amount of debugging
functionality that's in the mathematic
of front-end also in workbench
I think what's in the workbench is a
little more involved than what's in the
front of traditional as well yeah it's
more traditional yeah but but it's you
know it's certainly the case that we
haven't plowed a lot of effort into
improving it we you know continue to
maintain and keep it at parity but we
haven't plowed a lot of effort into
improving it as you suggest and you know
basically you know these sorts of things
that's that's why we had these
conferences you know I'd like to hear
from you it's you know is this something
that really should be on our radar you
know is it something that that one or
two percent of our users care about or
is it something that that ten or twenty
percent of our users care about and
there was a very loud sort of
communication from you guys about
multiple on dude that influenced their
internal priorities and we listen to you
so just kind of curiosity for maybe a
show of hands like debugging better
debugging functionality who who really
wants that would lose it critical okay
well that's a good show fan that's at
least fifty percent I think of the room
so that's good to know
next question is from Abraham Gedaliah
kadala kadala some of the presentations
that I visited that Mathematica crashed
without warning should Mathematica give
a warning first before clashes
Oh at least what do you do to stabilize
it I think I can even answer that way I
guess John once again because I think
you're assuming the the frenetic crashes
or the colonel yeah well a warning can
we give please give a warning before it
crashed I'm not sure that's sort of
warning if it really is impending would
be that useful but but certainly one of
the things which would be useful is to
be able to start back up where you left
off and you know this is a feature that
has been I mean it's been on my radar
for a while I
I think it's been on some of your radars
as well and I know how it's going to be
implemented but I also have a bunch of
other really desirable features that are
in that are in the pipeline as well so
it's difficult for me to make promises
on that front but but I think you know
two things one is we want to you know
keep the quality high so we don't
experience crashes in the first place
and and internally we're doing some very
interesting things on that front in
terms of we're modernizing our
development process internally in a way
that in a way that I think you know is
already showing some significant
improvements to you know just in the
last several months to quality and I
think that's going to make a big
difference going forward both in our
ability to you know maintain really high
quality versions of you know of the
software that we ship and also being
able to when we do discover bugs because
you know let's be realistic there you
know there's no way that we're ever
gonna ship bug free software you know
the only bug free software maybe is five
lines of code and frankly I wouldn't be
so
about that so the but but one important
way to respond is that if you know if we
do make a mistake being able to get
fixes out there quickly and this is
something that we really have a very
significant internal engineering effort
on and I you're gonna you're already
seen just the crest of that just the
beginning of the crest of that but
you're gonna see be seen some changes
and how we deliver software I think over
the course the next year or so
yeah and and one small addition is that
we we have to pack let manager to update
bucks in the field as well so you know
if we discover issues after release you
know in certain areas we can actually
you know fix things in the field you
know as we find out about them yeah
we're doing that right now actually
there was there was an issue that came
out that was caused by the mistake in
the predictive interface and it's right
at this very moment I think we're
approving a new version of that code
that's gonna go out to everyone who's
using it so next question is from Bailey
saner haider so biological sciences have
become largely data-driven and from
atomic scale structures to a system
level integration between proteins to
physiological integration between cells
you have data data data and I think
Mathematica has left this area largely
orphaned and I would like to hear from
you if there are long-term plans to have
Mathematica become more friendly to the
interfaces of biophysics biochemistry
the more data driven experiment meets
theory and between the two now to admit
of course there's some functionality in
there already you can visualize basic
molecules you can even look at PDB files
representing proteins but in terms of
what is practiced there is I think a
large gap between where Mathematica is
where a practitioner would like to be so
there is there's nothing in a sort of
major project going right now on that
it's always being brought up as
something we should do but you know to
my knowledge there is no there's no
major initiative that's that's sort of
underway right now it's more sort of in
the planning stages so at this time I
think what would be useful is to hear
what kinds of things details yeah what
kinds of things that you're looking for
would be really constructive we fire up
new projects pretty quickly so this this
can flip around in a matter of weeks
zero to order request there probably is
support for common experimental file
formats such as I mean PDB is there
already that for example afm surface
data it's a billion format just picking
one out of many many many I mean
structural system biologists deal with
completely different things I mean every
time somebody has to deal with data like
this coming in and being parsed yeah and
being manipulated thing that you do is
write your own parser which is several
days of waste of time for every
practitioner I think right those have
got it that's good actually that's
useful that's true but there's of course
some very obscure file formats that you
know may not be useful for us to support
you know because it's such a small but
of course if anyone you know it's
written something it's always great to
share that you know in the various you
know github for community I mean it does
a great places do you know if someone
has done it that particular thing I mean
it's kind of useful to bring up is that
the the import-export thing for instance
of file formats it is extensible and
it's documented how to extend it and to
make that very slick as just as the ones
that we've written a new one plug into
the same framework and so on ensuring
that as orna point out it's important
and we hope to make that a lot easier
going forward this year with a
marketplace or an app store that makes
it very easy to share those kinds of
things because there will always be a
you know however fast we go and however
if we got ten times bigger in terms of
development capacity there would still
be a lot of things outside of that
that one would like to do and would like
to have available so I think that this
marketplace our being able to share
share kind of work is another important
thing for you guys to be able to publish
and do thanks do next question is from
Ron loop gain hi my question is a little
different it's not so much about
features it's more along the lines of
gentleman who asked about the UML how's
that better okay so the question is with
large collaborative projects you have to
have higher level artifacts than just
going into the code I kind of thought
that's what I heard the answer was to
his question was just going to code and
rename it very well
how does Wolfram internally do their
large collaborative projects when one of
the higher level architects what's the
methodology you're using for wolfram
itself I'm assuming that's going to be
the best practice for using Mathematica
so hmm I mean so we I can speak for
algorithm R&D okay the high level
projects have the feature in in
Mathematica we often go into new
territory that when no one has kind of
tried to take as an ambitious view of
putting things together ever before
which means that they're a little bit
surprises happening which means that we
often need to pivot kind of in the
middle of a project so we work on you
know we basically have maintained a lot
of notebooks that work at a pretty high
level that outlines the whole the whole
workflow the whole collection of
functionality and what we aim to sort of
achieve but as I said as we run into
stumbling blocks there's something that
may be impossible to do you can't really
drill through this particular problem or
there are problems that you're a little
bit hesitant about in an early stage but
you're actually able to drill through
even though no one has done it before in
which case you get sort of you know
really compelling functionality so we
maintain we iterate a lot you know we
write you know and this is what's good
about Mathematica you can actually
iterate a lot you can do this you can
take advantage of this you're able to
drill through this problem that you
wouldn't even sure it was solvable or
you can fall back you
to something else that turns out to be
sort of a not gonna be robust enough not
going to be fast enough or whatever it
is and so that ability to to pivot and
be flexible about it it's really crucial
to us particularly for new areas if it's
sort of filling out functionality and
something we've done before we know how
it's going to go and we use our
documentation system our reference pages
that you see we write those pretty damn
early we start writing examples pretty
damn early we do we stress the
functionality pretty early because a lot
of functionality take we have lots of
functions in Mathematica can never be
finished okay but they need to be good
enough like take some or solve or you
know or anything like that they're
they're very unbounded we could work and
solve for the rest of our lives
only and you know but but what we want
to do is to stress them and and and and
and get them to a good enough you know
beyond human capability as soon as
possible and we do that just routinely
by building the reference pages early
and by having more algorithmic
generation of stressing of it how do you
figure when you go into a new domain of
knowledge what domain what's your inputs
how do you figure out what you're gonna
open up next that are really what you
already have that's a really complicated
thing it's driven by you guys a lot it's
driven by internal developments that's
driven by dependencies among projects if
we do this then this this whole other
things are gonna open up and and it's
driven by what capabilities and people
and resources we have so that's a really
complicated process but we do we do look
a lot on but terms of what you guys care
about we have lots of bugs and
suggestions there's communities now
there are these kinds of gatherings so
you might not think that but every time
I talk to you guys hi that tweak sort of
you know the decision you know like
people really care about this you know
and multiple undo as John brought up
it's like God you know we've been
talking about it
it was one of these big enough project
that so many other projects needs to
move out in a way in order to be able to
do multiple undo for a system like ours
but at some point it comes to a crest
where it's like we got to do it you know
come hell or high water we have to move
all these other projects aside and we
got to do it okay next question is from
Alex Hirsch Bruner hi I'm with Nokia
networks and I had a question about the
cloud deployments that you have today
and I was curious with your cloud
deployments you know we we're gonna have
bandwidth constraints for many areas of
the world for some period to come and it
seems that there are many opportunities
where it's less expensive to download
the code for certain kinds of things
like image processing than to actually
send the actual data if you're not
interested in a particular you know a
new image that you're going to send
somewhere else and you just want to do
some analysis so I'm curious do you look
at the bandwidth constraints that exist
in the network and make decisions on
perhaps what functionality you might
send down as you know javascript code or
whatever beyond just the user interface
and or do you look at that do you see
yourselves looking at that in the future
I think that's Tom right I think yeah I
think that's that's that that's a really
interesting question and I'm not quite
sure I mean right now there's all sorts
of different sort of angles to it we
don't sort of dynamically monitor the
bandwidth to decide you know how rich of
an interface to send down or to delay
things we don't do that now I think just
in terms of the user interface
I could imagine us sort of optimizing
things to you know you know shipping
down a big notebook we might decide to
ship you know have different strategies
as to what we ship down based upon the
bandwidth I could imagine that being you
know a key part of optimizing large
notebooks that's that's the user
interface now you asked about data so
typically with data you would so in the
cloud the computation the
moment is very much running on the
server so you would you would upload
your data to the server and then you and
then you work on it so that's kind of a
very much you driven rather than us
driven because you decided to upload
your data now you're quite right that
ban words vary around the world and
quite dramatically there's sometimes
almost like different internets in
different parts of the world there are
solutions to these so one solution is a
thing called private cloud is is a
fantastic solution many of us who
develop the cloud products we actually
run it you know I have kind of the
equivalent of a private cloud on my
laptop and it works really well that if
I share that around a little cluster of
computers it gets tremendous performance
so a private cloud is a viable solution
I think related to that I think we're
probably going to have to start thinking
about sort of collocating cloud centers
in other regions of the world and we
started to have discussions with
partners for for exactly this foot foot
foot for exactly this time thing is that
is that answering your question yes I
was just curious also about though
downloading image processing
functionality rather for example because
in many cases I won't have a private
cloud available I just have an embedded
device that's sitting somewhere in a
cornfield right and let's say I want to
take a picture and I want to do some
image processing on it but I I can I
have enough processing locally to do it
so if you downloaded say the library
like you might have on your iPad that
you're writing before that might be more
efficient than I mean actually sending
you that well that that's I mean if your
embed if your device was a Raspberry Pi
you can do that now you don't have to
wait you can run you know you can run
Mathematica at them you know on neurons
your point at the moment most with some
fairly small not almost
aspirational examples you can't break
out part of like the image processing or
something
I think that's but increasingly to the
the compiled generated code absolutely
the set of things that go in there right
that can run on its own is will be
increase dramatically and the cloud
itself is is driving that because for
example if we can do the computations in
your browser rather than our cloud well
you know we don't pay the electricity
bill for your browser so and that's
that's exactly the sort of thing that
we're we're looking for now I I don't
know that we're going to be compiling
out our finite element though into sort
of JavaScript and having that run having
that run locally but where we've got a
program of things to do exactly
distributed computing pushing it down to
the you know the appropriate place in
the issue of image processing there are
all sorts of complicated issues with
libraries and things that we have to
sort of face and you know Roger sort of
alludes to and he's very good at seeing
these connections you see image process
I'm saying this as in I don't know this
and just image processing it
mathematically is not necessarily like
it was processing anywhere else because
it can live in Mathematica and it can
use all other features now I doubt that
image processing uses any graph theory
but but it might sorry it does actually
it does fine right that's that's the
really cool thing about Mathematica is
that when you know when you're an image
processing you know we have a bigger
image processing team when you're a
developer there you're you know you know
you don't have this sort of narrow view
of you know I'm doing image processing
it's you're you've got opportunities to
pull in all sorts of other things and
that's that's that's that's what makes
it lots of fun to work on so you see so
then it's not just purely oh well I just
need to get this library down and work
on it but a lot of these things a lot of
these sensor networks distributed
sensors and stuff a lot of them are
powerful enough to actually run a
Mathematica runtime you know so then it
comes down to business models licensing
models and I think that that's actually
all evolving starting with a Raspberry
Pi and yet
and hopefully a whole slew after that so
I think that that's that's probably very
immediate you know talking here you know
over the course of a year or two the
compilation thing right okay the next
question is from Charles Grissom squish
them actually I'm sorry to do this but
I'm gonna bring back the issue of mobile
devices just for a couple of comments if
you don't mind if you subtract the
Wolfram employees from this crowd you've
got a pretty senior audience and I think
a lot of people are concerned about in
colleges and universities about trying
to get young people into using your
software which is beautiful and there's
two ways to do that one is here with
these things because every student walks
around like this all day long okay and
I'm afraid they're going to get hit by
cars when they do and things like that
and the other way is to have them use
your software in their academic pursuits
and so you'd say well just build cloud
applications the problem with that is
you're costing model puts the burden on
the people who develop those
applications now instead of the students
who use it and I'm very concerned about
that and I've talked to half a dozen
other people here this week who are
similarly concerned any comments well to
be honest I'm not the best person to
talk about what our costing models are
it's I'm not really familiar with the
details myself but one thing I can say
in you know in response to your first
point is actually you know I mean the
good news is we are very exposed to the
younger crowd and yeah it did take some
rethinking to to figure out how to do
that but a lot of times when you talk to
people who are in there people who are a
high school age college age they may not
be familiar with Mathematica that's
entirely true but they're very familiar
with Wolfram Alpha absolutely
and you know I interview people all the
time who are like Wolfram oh you're the
Wolfram Alpha folks and our our app for
accessing wolf alpha has done very well
and well actually I say our app we have
numerous apps that access Wolfram Alpha
but our principle app is done very well
even the verticalized apps that we have
for various courses have done well and I
think it's been and and you know you're
seeing kind of a bit of a merger of that
technology with Mathematica as well it's
going a bit both ways actually and so I
think I think drawing the younger crowd
into that is is something that we're
making decent progress on but in terms
of cost models it sorry I you were
expecting a better answer and I'm just
not the best person to give it well I
have a few things to add about the
costuming you know like students they're
very familiar with you know mobile
phones like you said and but they're
also familiar with you know getting
subscriptions to you know like Pandora
or Netflix or any sort of cloud service
and they're used to you know like if
they think it's a valuable service then
you know that they're willing to pay for
it and then you know to some extent you
know you can think of a computation
service the same way and but of course
you know students are very money
constraint and so we have to have you
know free plans or very low cost plans
at the same time so it's definitely
something you know that needs to be
considered and I might add something
else along that so you know I totally
agree and it's amazing that that I see
cuz I meet young people my children or
college they they they think they
Wolfram Alpha is unbelievably popular
maybe what we haven't done and the cloud
might help from here is to transition
people from alpha 2 to Mathematica I
think that's that's another issue and in
fact like your or so ago we introduced a
subscription you know a premium version
of Wolfram Alpha with subscriptions and
that's actually being surprisingly
popular and it has vaccean surprisingly
popular amongst students yeah
exactly yes and I hadn't predicted that
but I'm a conservative guy I think what
we're missing and I think you're
absolutely right there and this is
something I'm taking home from talking
to people is the ability for people
building cloud apps in our cloud to be
able to pass on subs to conveniently
have a subscription-based mechanism for
their you know for users of the things
that they're building because I think
that there's our new days I think people
are willing you know if if the cost is
low and it solves real problems people
are willing to you know subscribe to
services give it a go it only it's only
a few dollars a month and then you know
your subscription or you know app for
pay apps I mean we need to make a
convenient way for apps to go through
our technology to build such things
that's there's a lot of improving yet to
do strengthen right I'm told it's 10
o'clock I deeply apologize to everybody
who had their hands raised and didn't
get their answered their question
answered but you know we're all around
and just approach us if you have any any
more questions on any of these topics so
thank you